[Applause]
now who's running for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up creek in the cave
wow it's good to be here we're gonna
watch people date tonight
some of them will need a condom
and luckily we provide that with our
sponsor trojan go check them out trojan
sponsored
thank you
wow a lot of safe sex practitioners
tonight
uh we always have a guest this guest is
a very funny woman not a big deal but
she is a woman and she has been on kill
tony before and is a very funny comedian
uh very a lot of fans this girl has give
it up for molly vivent
[Music]
molly vivens
coming in with the water and the
coca-cola
i stay strapped
damn
i mean she has a dildo she's gonna peg
someone tonight it's gonna be hans
have you
yeah
someone volunteering
who wants to watch subscribe to my only
fans thank you
check her out on millie vanilli no no no
no
no
how did i get so sexy you can find me
there on instagram molly how's your uh
and how's your kill tony appearances
been are you uh are you getting a lot of
unrequested dms
yeah a lot of them
what is the tenor of those messages some
of them are really nice every once in a
while there's a mean one but a lot
also um
sexual advances
especially from like oh what's that like
the disabled community
don't talk about autistic people like
that we hate to be no i like them that's
why they're hitting me up because i
admitted to that
oh yeah kill tony molly famously
admitted that she is into [ __ ]
handicapped men
how do you think i got such a good
parking spot today
[Applause]
cody's
cody's heard that news he's about to
jump off a bridge so he can [ __ ] you
because
he wants to get disabled no yeah every
time i go to kill tony there's someone
that hugs me after and they whisper in
my like ear i'm [ __ ]
and i'm like listen if you were you
wouldn't know it
yeah
those [ __ ] people are [ __ ]
um
we got some names here so uh we pull out
the name and then we watch them go on a
date for one minute and then we
interview them so this should be fun
let's figure out who
the two lucky straights are tonight
we have one gay in the bucket
someone please come out of the closet
we need this guy's lonely don't be a
bigot
we got megan delaney coming up
a human being
hello yes there's stairs right over
there should i pull yes
pull it like it's a dildo in the man's
[ __ ] mike
mike
yeah it's mike oh mike
mike aka mchale
[Applause]
megan and michael sitting in a tree
whichever one you want
michael
[Music]
here we go mike and megan one minute of
dating starting now pick up the mics and
get at it
oh that's this isn't awkward but hi mike
nice to meet you i'm megan good to meet
you megan how you doing today i'm a
little bit
nervous but embarrassed but i'm good
just don't act like 20 people are
staring at us right now perfect perfect
oh
are you from austin i'm not i'm from
canada canada which part ottawa ontario
ah i've only been to quebec everyone
hates quebec no what
no
quebec has got french
quality food with american style
portions that is the best true but
everyone in quebec's an [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty pretty accurate
yeah i'm i'm from st louis and so like
i've come from a place where everybody
the minute you make eye contact whether
you know a person or not you're supposed
to say hello or how are you doing hello
yeah i know
no um
what what are you doing out here
um i came here six years ago because i
hate snow and i just ended up staying
oh how about you
end time give it up for mike and
megan
a lover of canada apparently you've been
to quebec of all places
pick up the mic please
i was a travel nurse and i was working
out in new hampshire oh okay and uh i
was uh it's like one day i told my buddy
i'm like just fly up here it's like
three hour to drive it's three hour
drive to montreal let's just do it and
that's how we did i got stopped at the
border apparently when they ask you if
you have weapons you're not supposed to
jokingly say only the ones god gave me
they stop you for that what a joke sir
you are the most midwestern person i've
ever met
[Laughter]
every time i go to the st louis airport
like i steer clear of you like that
person
what a jovial teddy bear
uh canadian why does everyone hate
quebec so much um i feel like it's the
equivalent of everyone in the us hating
texas
oh because they're so much better and
cooler than everyone else and they also
only want to speak french but like the
rest of canada doesn't
as opposed to whatever they the [ __ ]
they speak in texas that's not english
[Laughter]
so uh how do you like your freedoms in
america so far
um
i try i try to stay out of that scene of
things i just i'm actually you don't
like freedom no i try to stay in
politics
i can't vote i'm on a green card so i
stay out of politics
what if you marry an american man are
you gonna vote
maybe something will come out of tonight
let's say that you married mike
and you're about to vote in your first
american election oh god
what is one of the key
key issues that you're looking forward
to ticking the box on tonight
abortion you gotta say it a little bit
louder with your chest
[Laughter]
no choice speak for the baby that is
dead now
that's freedom and we love that
yeah you want you want to vote for
abortion
i think every woman should have the
right to choose what they want to do
with their body
period wow
don't be talking crazy now
no hans that's freedom we like our
freedom hell yeah
mike when's the last time you had an
abortion with the significant other
personally uh not i haven't had an
abortion yet
but you know who knows that you know
yeah your mother tried to abort you
by the size of your head you look like a
[ __ ] you should [ __ ] molly
a very handsome man
mike and molly's show i think that would
be there we go but wait i have a
question if you did knock a girl up and
she wanted abortion are you the type of
man to like pay for it completely or
you're like halfsies or are you like
you're paying for on your own
uh
i'm gonna honestly say that i'll
probably pay for it myself i feel
responsible for that with your credit
card to get like airline miles or
oh how do you think i get to travel so
much yeah you want to go back to quebec
kill the fetus and go to canada
it's romantic
yeah
we can't do that i don't know if i would
take it that far
there's not like a honeymoon for
abortions
it's called florida
that's where i'm from
hell yeah mike is killing it wow what
are you at a customs office right now
i had my abortion in florida
[Music]
congratulations yeah and then yeah i
felt like i was on a vacation the whole
time i was like
i'm in a bora bora
[Laughter]
it was nice
that was your only abortion i find that
hard to believe no it was
i'm not kidding i used to be addicted to
getting
came inside of but
i truly didn't get pregnant until i was
on wellbutrin ladies it'll get you
pregnant and i live by that don't be on
wellbutrin
nice
some good advice
from dr molly
make sure to
get all your
ob gyn information from comedians
um
technically you know
it's like antidepressants can affect
your uh
can affect your libido
boner what's the
erection
is what they give to people that ssris
don't work on because they have
they're
they can't get it up because of their
antidepressant so they switch you to
wellbeing well i could get it up and
then we'll
and then well
actually made me so skinny and then it
made me pregnant so it was like
a bad friend
giving a take it affects your birth
control that's what i was trying to say
antidepressants can affect your brain
i've never been on birth control
[Laughter]
yeah he's like these liberal women with
their birth control they're all on it
um but mike you asked uh where are you
from she said canada and then you said
which one
there was only one canada
where i said or which part maybe yeah
yes
i disagree
you take it back to the gym mike how's
st louis you uh you survived the murder
capital of america
are you uh
are you from west st louis
uh i'm actually from the central west
end i live in the central west end there
yep checks out melanin wise
[Music]
how was uh how was your tenure in st
louis you're out you can speak freely
now
i haven't been shot yet
so that's a plus well welcome to texas
we don't do that here
[Laughter]
so if you were gonna take her on a date
or like if you were gonna eat a meal
with her would it be like toasted
ravioli that's a st louis thing or would
it be like poutine like are you trying
to show her your culture or experience
hers
first of all have you ever had putin
yes i have
sorry i'm a boot to try putin
[Laughter]
i'm gonna honestly go t-reps because uh
you can get well there's a lot of places
of poutine around the united states but
there's like
i think st louis is one of the few
places you can actually get t-rex from
well i mean you could just get ravioli
and then fry it
that's a lot of work anywhere in the
country you can do that
deer head is that what you said
deer head
that's what i heard no i don't think
that's what he said uh it's toasted
raviolis or
breaded and deep-fried raviolis that
sounds good oh they're delicious
yeah yeah it's good it's american way to
get canned cheese so you would not be
interested in her culture at all if you
guys were on a real date
i would be perfectly fine with it i'm
not opposed
you're not opposed to canadians what a
what a gentleman
uh what's the weirdest thing that is
different about dating in canada versus
america
um
do you want the true answer yes the true
answer [ __ ] the lack of health care
i'm worried everyone's gonna like shoot
me no no yes everyone get your guns
ready we're about to shoot a canadian
tonight no one's gonna shoot you
just make sure the mic is pretty close
to your mile
[Laughter]
sorry
it sounded like a threat
you keep letting that mic drift away
he's gonna
you might have to work yeah he sends you
back to canada right here
what uh what's this
what's this answer that you're so afraid
of saying oh i have words are gonna
shoot me yeah oh and on a date yeah oh i
thought you meant the audience
yeah that was guns
no i i don't think someone's gonna shoot
you
you never know have you watched in
canada i'm afraid someone's gonna
slap me on the head with a hockey stick
accurate that actually does happen
sometimes
yeah i know that's their baseball bat
um but yeah so you're afraid of getting
shot
everything in that genre
yeah you're not afraid of getting the
vaccine and shot up by some strange
drugs both in health care so i feel like
nice
we're not afraid of getting the vaccine
how is it to make money in health care
unlike in canada
um that's part of the reason i moved
here i'm not gonna lie so you're against
universal healthcare i am
okay
it's not as good as you all think it
sucks
yeah yeah but you love abortions
i don't love that she just wants you to
pay up for them that's like
that's fine that's what biden is for
mike are you vaccinated
triple vexed hell yeah
that's a little much
i got sick with it and it was
terrible
you got sick with it after you were
triple vac no i got sick with it before
that's why i'm triple vaxxed but like
you don't think the antibodies would
have helped you well they the thing is
vaccines just help boost it so your body
doesn't forget
yeah i guess i hate it when my body
forgets and i will say
again with the aids
[Laughter]
i'm triple backs and i've not had covet
and i work in an er so
oh you're the enemy it works
nice congratulations
you did it hopefully you don't get shot
did i say that now i'm gonna get
yeah it's not that bad right now
it's like the cold what about monkey pox
are you guys already vaccinated
i i'm actually a vaccinate for smallpox
it's the same vaccine
yup so you are monkey pox vaccinated
yeah is that why you got it
no i uh got it when i was a baby because
i was born in russia and they were still
vaccinating for smallpox when i was born
there oh
old are you
34. oh okay that sounded a lot older
than 34.
well so the specific area i'm from they
stopped vaccinating for smallpox in like
92 and i was born in 88 so russia adds
10 years
mikhail uh what do you think about the
ukraine right now
oops well so
i can see why you went by mike tonight
uh yeah it's um
so where i'm from at the time wasn't a
country now it is is belarus belarus is
like the mexico of russia so whatever
russia says belarus does
and um because they that's their entire
trade
and they produce potatoes and tractors
so you're like ukraine step in line be
be like us obedient i i said this one
time i said this before and i'll say it
again and this was in a group like a
group of russians i go i live in america
now so [ __ ] russia
hell yeah
anything you want to say canada to
mother canada right now
yeah
do you think canada is just a bunch of
communists
[Laughter]
just a reminder you are in texas right
now so answer accordingly i think the
canadian political system is actually
very different than the american
political system so that's all i need to
know there's a lot more sorries but do
you miss the prime minister's a lot more
black hot even in black face he's hot
he's hot but he's not the brightest
person in the world but he is hot even
with blackface and a turtle it's because
his only qualification to be prime
minister was he was a calvin klein model
he was a what calvin klein model yeah
that's hot dude
reagan was an actor and he's a [ __ ]
superhero right it's like an interesting
state so didn't he like create crack
supposedly
i think he did
and he put it in the black community i'm
just going to say that
i learned that on tick tock doctor and
historian molly vivent really spitting
facts tonight
uh yeah uh justin trudeau is great you
know good job on that um
you ever uh
you ever
try to like uh kate whatever him kate
middleton him try to like marry into the
royal family well for now
do you know anyone who's [ __ ] him
no
i've never even seen him in real life
who's your coolest eskimo sister do you
have one that's like
like a famous one
no i
have a lot of friends that did travel
nursing up north so lived on
like
what do you call it
thank you they've done reserves oh i
think you didn't get what eskimo sister
meant i probably didn't
they don't have this term in canada
eskimo's sister is people that [ __ ]
the same person
[Music]
but actually it's here not in canada
in here in austin yeah who's your
coolest eskimo sister can you say
grimes
is it grimes no
did you [ __ ] elon musk he went to my
alma mater we went to the same time it
was oh no
she's pregnant right now that's why she
loves abortion so much
i would not abort that he's gonna have
his
11th kid
yeah just pop one out get a paycheck
exactly uh
have you ever dated a russian before
isn't that kind of scary to date a
russian no i've actually been to russia
oh okay god damn it this canadian is up
to something really nice there from what
i saw i feel like a lot of it is
stereotypical but i mean i was only
there for two days so
okay so uh they don't drink a lot of
vodka
they do drink a lot of vodka
and they teach you how to shoot it
correctly
did you have borscht i did okay do you
think you could live on boris for the
rest of your life with this
bear of a man mikhail borsch is [ __ ]
delicious
it's my favorite
white people
[Laughter]
white people say the darndest thing
if you were a real eskimo like we were
talking about earlier what you thought i
was talking about
and you were in the
post shift right now
if you were in the frozen tundra like
would michael be a good person to cuddle
up with and stay warm i'm all about i
have very warm hands and he has a good
personality oh my god that's the meanest
thing you could have ever seen no i mean
you know it was night shift i'm tired
this canadian is a [ __ ]
i have been told i'm the meanest
canadian people know you're gonna need
universal healthcare after you get beat
the [ __ ] up outside
you kind of are a mean canadian like he
was like oh i've been to quebec and
you're like everyone hates that place
i only speak the truth that's how racism
looks like in canada i guess yeah
i just [ __ ] the french pretty much
a guy
my last name is vivo so
i don't we have beef probably i like i
like france french
they wouldn't like you french people do
not like people from north america at
all
if you tip them well they love you
i don't think so
i got lots of free concert tickets from
the desk people it's like well none of
my family members like me and i
have tipped them plenty i feel like oh
[ __ ] you're a quebec quebecois
no my family's from france oh [ __ ]
my dad grew up in canada though mikhail
could you ever date a canadian who
doesn't even believe in freedoms or
french
god
i would see a reason why not
already adapting to the customs of his
future wife
[Laughter]
you don't have to kidnap her you just
consensually ask her in this country
wait will you say the last three letters
of the alphabet really quick okay we all
know we say it the right way
x y and zed
z is that right people
is the last letter of the alphabet zed
no she thinks she's right she's not
shame her
that's too bad i've been here six years
i've started to say z
mainly for my job because there's
something called a z pack and every time
i say zed pack the pharmacy doesn't know
what i'm talking about
yeah they shouldn't because this is
america
speak english
give it up for megan and mike
they went on a date
you can always sign up the more the
merrier we got a man coming up named
a woman i guess lisa
peron
oh too many there she comes from the
back
sorry about all that talk about quebec
people yeah
okay
jake hastings come up jake wow jake
hastings really playing the field
tonight
he's come here with his girlfriend and
he's going on a date
with his girlfriend
i'm sorry i called you a [ __ ] canadian
megan i actually do like you please sign
up
30 or 60 seconds starting now
are you into freaky [ __ ] yes yeah what's
your best fetish
my best what best fetish
i don't know what that is you don't know
what a fetish is oh fetish yeah
um
licking ass
licking ass i'm into it
yeah yeah i'm into it
when you want to do it tonight because
she's got to join that
that i really like there you go
solved
what's your name i'm lisa
yeah jake that's keys my girlfriend hi
nice to meet you
you too
i love you tats nice
she's into licking ass is she yeah okay
well maybe it's just
done done and done
he's gonna let this keep going
do you want hans to join
hey you like licking ass too
okay there you go
problem solved
and time give it up for this freaky
couple
these girls better not be on wellbutrin
no no
no
lisa looking like the mom from
smallville tonight you got the uh
farmer's wife get up
what uh what brings you all the way into
town into austin
well my boyfriend maybe
oh [ __ ] there's gonna be a foursome wait
wait wait wait wait
wait was that just the what are we while
you're on stage did you just what are we
to him like you don't know it's gonna
get really weird oh i just kind of
pushed that out have you ever had a
third in your uh relationship
yes
oh [ __ ]
because i know jake has done that before
what a boy or a girl
a girl yeah just once
no
was it more for you or for him it was
for me
yeah you're gay yeah
she wanted to come for the first time
who's your boyfriend is he back there
he's hiding hey
it's a maybe boyfriend let's look at the
luckiest boyfriend in the world right
now
he's got glasses on
so i like him like that double
uh how did this happen did you ask him
or did he ask you
i asked i got bored
yeah you're like too many penises here
let's dilute the supply of penis
one is too many yeah i agree yeah
yeah sorry man
so what was the configuration was it uh
scissoring or 69
gliding and lightning gliding gliding
yeah what's gliding wait what like
gliding no no no like sugar gliders
sort of yeah like the animal what the
[ __ ] is gliding it's kind of gliding you
know oh just like rubbing your bellies
together rubbing your clits together
yeah like scissoring but no
sort of but not really yeah gliding
that's awesome what was your boyfriend
doing while you were gliding
he was hoping he's helping the glide he
was like moving one person up and down
now he was just kind of like you know
giving us a little help from
what are you doing with your fingers
right now
french tickler
fingering your [ __ ] while you're
gliding you look just like the woman
from smart house
from what the disney movie i don't know
what that is
she does
90s kids know what we're talking about
i didn't know the lady from smart house
was freaky like that
[Laughter]
jake have you ever heard of gliding
before um no but i think i get the
general gist yeah we'll practice yeah
it sounds nice sounds like a lot of lube
involved
jake what is the what is the freakiest
thing that you've done with your
girlfriend
freakiest put you on blast baby
[Laughter]
uh just um randomly picking up random
women and basically just [ __ ] them
wherever we want to wow but like with
consent of course okay what are the
chances that you two meet together you
guys are both
you know doing the same thing yeah wait
is that the intention here no
but it worked
[Laughter]
are you guys going to cha cha glide
after this
[Laughter]
one half this time
that's awesome guys i hope really that
you guys do something tonight freaky
uh so how did you meet your boyfriend
lisa hinge
hinge wow okay was it an option to be
like i'm into gliding or threesome no no
no no he just met normally yeah just you
sprung it on him
wait you're talking about you've done a
third with the gliding in the past
relationship yes so like have you guys
done anything freaky this new guy that
you don't know
is the sex good
it's pretty good yeah hell yeah dude
he's got protractors he's got his
glasses on
i would like i love
he's pretty hot i think he's hot what's
his ethnicity
he's a white jew
so am i that's crazy
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you guys got competition
molly's gonna try to slide in and glide
right she can glide
[Laughter]
so jake uh do uh
what do you like about threesomes so
much
it's always a new adventure and she's
amazing and she loves women and i love
women and it just worked out so
wait can you tell us about a bad
threesome experience bad
experience
um because those happen almost got in a
fight at a swingers club
not us almost fought somebody else at a
swingers club we were banging a girl
together and this guy comes in
and so we're on a bed and he comes in to
watch and he says yeah
slide on that dick [ __ ]
and he says that to her while she's
riding me
and i launched her off of me i got up to
fight the guy
full [ __ ] hard on
screaming at this guy the security comes
and gets him i turned around she didn't
miss a beat she's over there licking the
other girls
[Laughter]
[Music]
i was about to beat some dude's ass butt
naked and she wasn't even watching
you're like don't ever degrade my [ __ ]
while i'm [ __ ] that's yeah
not cool you're a good guy
she was like oh you guys are [ __ ]
well let me [ __ ] too
there you go she got a little distracted
by [ __ ] while you were
staring at some dude's dick were you
guys in part of that like swinger life
before you guys were together or was it
something you got into together a little
bit but mostly when we got together just
like we let our freak flags fly
damn
gross
you guys are an abomination to
everything christian yeah
you guys should move to canada
preferably quebec
[Laughter]
so lisa where did you uh
what do you think about uh you know
where did you meet your boyfriend
here in austin yeah on hinge right right
on him oh i've already asked this
[ __ ] the first night was that did you
[ __ ] the first night no no no i knew i
liked him so i hailed off
because you saw act like a man think
like a lady in the movie
no you're supposed to hold out
no no i just know like if i don't really
care for a dude i'll [ __ ] them yeah if i
just want to get that's what i hope you
don't care about me
this guy sucks let me [ __ ] him real
quick
han wants hans wants to glide he wants
to glide yeah i have a very small penis
so it would be like a lesbian gliding
situation it's just like a glitch oh
yeah yeah
just hang gliding a really big [ __ ]
yep
nice
we can work with that
so uh lisa what do you think about the
uh dating scene in austin did you uh
have a lot of success or
you know well
it's interesting yeah it's
a lot of dog dog walks on dates
well my first date with my boyfriend was
a walk because of covid i met him during
all the kovitz stuff were you guys
wearing masks
no
but we were saying two feet away ready
to lick ass
yeah
yeah so what got you into looking ass
just trying something different
you just give it one lick like a postage
stamp
you get all up in it
you you go to town like it's poutine
like it's poutine is it like you're into
mutual ass licking or like you just
really like licking someone else's it's
mutual ass licking yeah okay which one's
better though
well of course to yourself right like
someone doing it to you i don't know
some people are pleasers
and that's what gets them off yeah yeah
if you got a really sensitive tongue
yeah you look like you love to suck dick
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow i do too so i can say that i don't
love it but i know i look like i do
holy [ __ ] you can say that to people i
didn't know that was legal
if you're a woman you can objectify
other women and they like it usually
like they'll be like yes [ __ ] you made
my day like i just walk up to someone on
the street i'm like you have the fattest
ass i've seen in my life and they're
like
yes thank you
but if you did that they would call the
police oh yeah i know
i've been down into the holding cell
before and that's why being a woman in
america and especially texas is
the best because you can verbally
assault people
you can't get an abortion
but you can objectify women yes nice
there's a trade-off cause is a
miscarriage so
two words no it doesn't hans i don't
know
i don't think it does what if you're get
superman and you're like what'd you say
and then the baby no girls like it
ladies if i told any of you that you had
the fattest nicest ass i've seen all day
you wouldn't have a miscarriage you
would [ __ ] want to [ __ ] me you'd be
excited
it would be a police situation we proved
absolutely nothing with that
i'm glad we went through it
uh so you guys uh
think that you guys would go on another
date maybe bring your significant others
maybe they'd hit it off
yeah yeah definitely right like so how
would it work a
foursome a room
the dudes would watch while you guys
glide and then maybe you guys would swap
but i don't think that's definitely
would you do anything with a dude
no
no i guess we're watching while the
gliding is gliding
yeah
but like are you weird about it like i
know you wouldn't do anything but like
if there was like an orgy happening and
like a dick actually touched your
forearm like would you be up in arms
about it just put it in your mouth yeah
it's nothing weird it keeps it out of
the way yeah
if everyone's kissing and there's like a
dude and you're not just gonna kiss him
just because you know everyone's doing
it
it sounds like you put a lot of thought
into that do you sometimes do you
sometimes wish it was two guys though
yeah yeah so you guys do it though like
two guys
sometimes
that's so funny we have such different
points of view and i do love to eat
[ __ ]
but when i'm at work because i work in
porn like
i love threesomes with other girls or
like multiple people with girls because
there's so much less work to do with the
dick
like by the time the video's over like
i've touched it twice because there's so
much other [ __ ] happening
the dicks per second is very low
yeah
so uh you guys are a freaky bunch of
people where do you guys usually do your
hedonistic activities is it like under a
bridge somewhere
ladybird lake
zelker park sounds like you've got ideas
heb parking lot
[Laughter]
buckies mostly
[Laughter]
you gotta get that beaver
yes
[ __ ]
i was there last night
give it up for jake and lisa
they're gonna create two babies tonight
[Music]
we got one more man and one more woman
it's the adam and eve story
we got julia oresborne coming up
and give it up for cody where's cody
here's julia oresborn
and cody
remember you can sign up still the
bucket is still available
please sign up
cody
[Music]
aficionado
comedy lover and julia orsbourne
i think it's osborne give it
give it up for oresborne and record
hello hello
um nice to meet you um do you go out to
comedy shows often i've never been to a
comedy to show before oh fun i remember
when this was the first comedy show i'd
been to in ever and
i keep coming back because it's
entertaining i hope it is it's i like it
so far it's it's different yes
i really don't know what to make of the
last people up here it was at the same
time too realistic and it just seemed
unreal it's pretty graphic but yeah it's
fun i was like sure i was like these are
great people i
i believe it but want no part of it
fair that's fair are you from here i am
yes okay
uh i'm from round rock actually which is
just north of here but okay i was gonna
say i don't know where that is it's all
grown together into some massive
central conglomerate and i'm here on
vacation so
everything's right over my head blurs
together where are you vacationing from
um southern indiana southern indiana
yeah i can't say this is much more
exciting than southern indiana are you
having a good time here it's fun yeah
and time
give it up for julia and cody
they had a very polite date this is like
a meeting of the chess club right now
it's that hoosier hospitality
i don't know what she said i think like
it's an indiana thing they're called
hoosiers
who's yours but we're looking for
hoovers
but it's okay we like you i was gonna
say cody
i think during the day she wanted you to
ask like where are you from but she kind
of just had to say it like i think you
need to like
try to ask more questions like if
someone asks you the question then you
redirect it back because they probably
want
to tell you it's fair it's easy as [ __ ]
just put in your programming and your
line of code
for dates
uh so cody where are you from you're
from round rock yeah uh what do you
think about uh
you know how everyone's making fun of
round rock like calling it like
shitty pflugerville and like
yeah i didn't know people were calling
that that and i guess if i were
someone that especially cared i'd be
upset but i don't like that's okay how
round is your rock if you know what i
mean so you have no pride
no i had no i went to round rock high
school and i had zero school pride i i
couldn't care less
round rock more like pound [ __ ] you're
gay
i think he wasn't pounding [ __ ] and
that's why he didn't have any school
spirit
you don't get that bandana from not
[ __ ] [ __ ] no i was not
no i was not pounding [ __ ] in high
school
or [ __ ] anything you weren't yeah no i
was i was that's why you had no school
spirit dirty person in high school
you would have been at every homecoming
dance if you had just gotten a little
strange
probably
cody
spirit now so close to me no you're not
getting laid no
he works with bees
i can't even remember you being on here
before been on here several times have
you been laid since
i'm trying to remember the last time you
were on and the last time i was here
when you were on and the last time you
got you no i don't think so
wow
you're doing great
let's help him julia's right here
hey
so uh what do you think about uh cody
you know he's a very able-bodied man
he knows the lay of the land he could
help you out like squanto
what uh what what do you like to do in
uh austin like you're from indiana there
must be something that you can't do
there here
that's actually a good question i don't
know
what do you do there
like in indiana what do you do
i look at corn
you look at corn
is this a tick-tock trend like you don't
even glide on it
all we have is corn and limestone
corn and limestone indiana is going
crazy over here i don't know we do we do
normal stuff oh [ __ ] so you do a lot of
boring yeah like
so i think you would probably
go for
like he probably seems exciting
yeah comparatively
what would you guys do together nit
play board games no but i'm curious i do
love board games i like play games too
what do you look at the corn what does
the coin tell you when you look at it
what are you looking for in the corn i
kind of just analyze it is it is it okay
is the crops doing well or
is this going to be a bad season that's
that's fair my grandfather was a farmer
like full-on so that's important i get
that that's fine so you're like
primarily in agriculture i think you
guys are star-crossed lovers and this
was meant to be
and i wanna watch you take his virginity
tonight
that would be so cool let's live stream
it
what's the town that you're from called
bedford
bedford
at least it's not corn husk
from round rock
there's probably a cornhusker texas
there's any any small town name you can
think of it exists we have a santa claus
indiana yeah
i'd go to santa claus
sounds boring there's an amusement park
so it's not too boring but so what
brings you to austin
um
my cousin and friends
what are your cousin and friends doing
here they're getting married or they're
just chilling just visiting for fun it's
it's not dallas so
what's your beef with dallas
i don't have beef with dallas but
they're from dallas and i feel like they
probably have some gotcha yeah i know
they have yeah [ __ ] dallas
everyone hates dallas that's why you
guys are here it's the dallas cryers
club because they cry about dallas or
something
cody uh what do you think she's from
indiana what would you where would you
go first thing
uh i really don't know what is there in
indiana show her the mopac
oh am i showing her around
okay realistically i'd probably take it
around rock donuts because
hey
one person knows what i'm talking about
those are the best damn donuts around
better than voodoo donuts even though
those are on sixth street that guy got
laid in high school he has school spirit
i can just tell
he probably brought donuts to school
that's how you got laid in high school
yeah you should have tried it
why didn't you do that why don't you
bring it here tonight as an offering
nothing better on a date than donuts and
corn
exactly i mean bringing donuts to high
school is better than like people used
to smuggle pigs into my high school so
i mean donuts and corn sound like
americans food staples like that's what
you eat every day isn't it in america
yeah staples is what you used to keep
your bandana on
um
what do you think about uh cody is there
anything that uh strikes strikes you as
different than other guys that cody has
um i don't think i've ever seen anyone
wear a bandana like that
not in indiana
maybe uh
i'd probably get beat up before my hair
got this long in indiana
wait no
no
no there's some there's some long-haired
that's rednecks i mean people like to
look like duck dynasty oh that's fine
that's some pretty long hair that's fair
i forgot about that
um
is it like a receding hairline is that
why you do it or
my hair's fine
dude like i feel like we could queer-eye
you and you'd be it just got too long
and in my face so i started wearing the
bandana and i was like [ __ ] i hate how
much i like how i look wearing a bandana
so i feel like even if you did a bandana
like across the head like this would be
better than
did you choose the bandana or did the
bandana choose you i don't know
it's been in my closet for a long time
so maybe it chose me and just waited so
cody what uh what's going on with the
bees
they're well we committed registered
today we killed an unproductive queen
we're going to replace her wow that's
good to know it's good to say on a date
i kill queens
[Laughter]
um what uh
what do you think about that he works
with bees i'm a beekeeper
you guys have bees in indiana
we hope so wait wait do happy's
what's your job
i'm an admin assistant
for what uh at indiana university oh
nice college she catalogs corn
no i work with physicists
hell yeah
you don't get those glasses for free you
know you uh you have dirt
that's how i got mine getting calm on
the face by a physicist
uh cody what do you do besides
beekeeping uh i
manage now a team of support people
for a video game
so if you have problems with the video
game they can provide support
nice
it sounds bad i can't get past level 14.
yeah that's
i think we have a specific like
automated response that says just get
good but nicely
nice
sorry you suck at the game there's
nothing we can do we don't offer
coaching before you say too much would
you go on this donut date with him if
you lived here would you go on the donut
date are you paying for the donuts for
sure okay yeah
i like free food
that's fair what a jew
what what is your race
julia white she's aryan
aryan nation
i am white as heck
i'm just what a jew would say
[Laughter]
nice
we got try
professional jew here no yeah i could
tell she's aryan nation i've been
watching oz the show about prison and i
feel like you're like one of the
daughters that visit the area nation
people
you fit the exact person
julia loyal racist
good for you have you ever said the n
word be honest
i haven't no
boring indiana
i'm boring
what do you do when you're yelling at
the basketball team
you don't ever encourage your team by
discouraging your opponents what a bad
fan
uh let's play a little role-playing game
let's say that cody is in jail for white
supremacy and
you're just popping down to give him
some cookies that have knives in them
and the little uh throwing stars and uh
you're trying to convince him to
give up his aryan ways to come back to
you and your
seven children in trailer park in
indiana
and action
cody
cody
cody you gotta keep this up
you gotta come back the children are
starving i don't know how to make no
money
we don't have water anymore
the farm's gone under
[Music]
please
jaspro misses his father
i can't you know what i stand for
can't change my mind like that
just you don't have to voice it you
could just pretend in the back of your
head
nobody has to know
i have to do damn it don't ask don't
tell i don't remind myself how will i
know
unseen give it up for julia
roberts apparently you are an actress i
am a voice actress that's my degree is
acting
[ __ ] that was the answer i was looking
for when i was like what do you know why
did you say assistant to an assistant or
whatever total of a hundred dollars
voice acting so it's not a great job no
that was more than i've made i was so
good i was disappointed i could really
he didn't do the n-word and i thought he
was going to pull missed opportunity
could really feel the indiana in your
voice that wasn't even an indiana accent
what what what dialect was where was
that
vaguely vaguely country i don't know
like
if i were to talk in my dna accident it
would talk should be the name of your
country album
but also i'd have to say ain't like i
don't know
okay
well you know it's great you know it's
clearly spent a lot of time with corn
talking to corn
hell yeah brother
her sister
uh cody uh
what did you think about uh sharing the
stage with such a accomplished thespian
i i was thrown and reminded why i didn't
take uh theater in high school
yeah you were laughing quite a bit for a
white supremacist they're not really
you made me the right supremacist that's
not something i chose i've never
met as like goofy of a white supremacist
before what a jovial racist
this guy hates with joy in his heart
uh i feel like the swinger make
something bring him to the swingers club
oh please no something
we just need to get you out of your
little shell i i really believe in you
get you out of your bandana yeah your
bandana and into a condom
i feel like i should take your bandana
from you like snatch it off of yourself
he's taking his virginity if you take
his like bandana from him he might feel
very attached to me after yes okay
i kind of figured
it's called pegging
[Laughter]
shove that bandana where the sun don't
shine
i feel like you love corn and like
indiana i'm gonna shove a corn cob up
your ass yeah
they say country girls make do
that's true let's do another scene where
julia you're a dominatrix in washington
dc and cody is an erstwhile politician
with a head full of ideas and uh
empty [ __ ]
and he's just come in for a little
appointment let's uh let's see how this
goes down it's starting now action
welcome cody wait who am i
he's not very good at this be vulnerable
that's what acting takes just do it
be like a politician that hates gays but
is secretly gay yeah
oh
howdy i'll just act like greg abbott oh
[ __ ] it's ted cruz
off to cancun
i don't even know what to say to that
do you like pegging ted cruz
yeah why ted cruz like peggy dominatrix
i'm sorry
virgins they're both virgins
it's my first night as a dominatrix i'm
sorry
but you are obviously cruz i'm not
you're not i'm not i'm not a virgin
either do you cosplay
i do yeah
yeah i know your exact type actually do
they have comic-con in indiana we have
indiana comic-con yeah
is that where the corn dresses up
yeah
that's cool you guys have uh culture
there you guys get japanese
stuff
do you own like tentacle dildos do you
know what i'm talking about i know what
you're talking about and no i don't
yeah i really she's not part of this
couple right now mine are like normal
they're normal and not tentacley but you
have a lot of dildos sure we'll say that
a lot what's a little are you like a
secret cam girl i feel like that's
no
that didn't sound convincing
i mean i've thought about it but now
i'm not
yeah she's a physicist or she like helps
businesses no she's like an assistant to
an assistant to someone yeah who is a
physicist
you just don't want to admit you're a
cam girl in front of your like dallas
cousins or something
they're gonna tell aunt susie
and you're gonna be in big trouble with
your mom
she's not
she's not
nah i'm not
not a cam girl i should be apparently
but i'm not currently no yeah i think
you'd be molly's a recruiter i am
i can tell i'm i'm feeling very
recruited right now
i'm not like him
it's fine cody have you ever done
anything sexual in public
maybe on camera he's never done anything
sexual huh why do you think he's a
virgin he's a very sexually healthy
young man defied in public not on camera
i haven't done anything on camera but
public depends on where you draw the
line like masturbating on the bus like
no but i [ __ ] someone in the park so
like a squirrel no
we're into that kind of thing in indiana
so
it's called an indiana glory hole
perfect size
have you ever pegged a squirrel
not yet
it could be your first cam girl thing
wait petting a squirrel
pegging oh no yeah that's different
petted a squirrel but no i've never
pegged
how many squirrels have you pat
have i pet or pegged pet
a couple
a lot of the dicks in indiana look like
squirrels because they're so hairy
um cody anything you want to say to
julia right now
i don't know i've laughed a lot with you
i'd like to get to know you more
oh add her on facebook i don't have
facebook myspace i don't have myspace
either
julia anything you'd like to say to cody
wait maybe like dating advice for his
next date right like what would like
just definitely bring a squirrel to the
park with you next time
i don't know how to respond to that
you don't have to
nights get lonely up in corn country
this is reminding me of high school and
i would like sometimes walk by the nerd
table and they would be talking about
weird [ __ ]
and then i would just keep walking and
not talk to them that was crazy this is
like a deleted scene from superbad
[Laughter]
super weird
uh but give it up for julia and cody
they dated each other
we got a couple more people
oh [ __ ] this is the julia from the first
one
this is the same couple why don't we
have the couples
come up keys
come up go on a date with and the baby
boyfriend boy the baby boyfriend come on
come on up your girlfriend went up come
on you can too
see you
yes
here he comes
[Applause]
they didn't even sign up
go ahead and sign up we need one more
couple
we got the boyfriend sauntering up like
he's going to another threesome
boring i've done so many of these
what's your name
andrew going on a date with keys
starting now
hey there hi
good to meet
you right back at you
can i just jump in yeah
what is your relationship status
yeah um
committed but sort of open sort of open
yeah i think
am i in trouble
oh i'm sorry that's
sorry that's so private i realize that
we're on stage again i'm really high
and
i forgot where we were because i can't
see anybody so
okay so if it's too private we could
stop no not i'm i'm open book okay ask
all you want and so
you guys are open and play separately or
play together
um well we haven't done it yet but i
think we would play
openly like together yeah i think so
okay we only play together
so
he's he's my man i need him in
everything we do together oh yeah well
it's really i enjoy it i love to watch
him
um with another woman it's and time
give it up for andrew and keys
[Music]
who almost made all the men in the room
come just now
i'm not kidding i felt a tingle
it was kind of like your voice was
really quiet when you were saying it was
hot
it was like i was in a sex club watching
my boyfriend [ __ ] someone else
what is it that you like about that keys
well it's like every woman wants the man
where all the women want him that turns
us on for my man to
be the
affection of someone else that's that's
sexy to me that means other
women like what i have
yeah it's like having a tivo
and other people want a tivo yeah
you always want like the alpha male and
if other women want him then i want to
share it's sexy
what a beautiful sentiment could you
talk to my ex
she does not agree with that do you ever
get jealous though of course of course
but you like feeling jealous
yeah it's kind of like a little you're
tiptoeing around it you know tabasco
sauce
you're a vanilla [ __ ] no
yeah of course i get jealous but we work
you know i just tell him that i'm
feeling insecure and he shows me that
i'm i'm his and how does he show you
does he
he just he gives me the comfort that i
need if i feel insecure i tell him and
he gives me hugs and kisses and extra
attention and
extra attention is that what he calls
his dick his attention i thought you
were the man but now it's sounding a
little gay
let me unfurl the extra two inches i
didn't use for the other girls
uh andrew love your smile you have the
smile of a man that just got his ass
licked when's uh
i wish
you guys haven't i thought you guys did
that that was the thing with you guys
maybe later tonight maybe later hell
yeah a man about to get his ass licked
have you ever uh gone down on your
girlfriend oh yeah of course nice yeah
you have npr vibes of course you go down
on your girlfriend
what uh what did you she like it more
than she wants it i think
you love a good culinary
experience
what uh what do you like so much about
eating puss i don't know that's a great
question i don't know i just like doing
it maybe you like the smell
it doesn't bother me i love the smell
it's all about the smoke that's stank
sting you kind of like a little bit of
that umami
taste in the back of your throat it's
like miso soup yeah
i'm sorry it's okay you only get that
with an asian girl
no my boyfriend always says he likes it
a little pungent
i've been with her for over two years
and she doesn't smell
ever like she doesn't have be like it's
weird it's freaky but are you sure i
hate her girlfriend isn't just like a
sex robot you design in your basement
you [ __ ] like the smart house sex dog
you're right he created the perfect
woman
you look like you should have your own
food network like show
right bobby flay's little brother why
you just have the face for it it's just
great it looks like you use fancy words
and eat fancy cheeses what kind of
shampoo do you use
head and shoulders
do you suffer from dandruff that's toxic
masculinity
keys uh what do you think about this guy
what are you have you ever met his kind
in an orgy can you sum him up
um
[Music]
i'll i'll do an assumption
do you like to
watch your woman be [ __ ] by another
man
i haven't but
oh [ __ ]
but more than likely you would be okay
with it
i maybe
maybe i don't know maybe but if she
wanted it you would give it to her right
yeah yeah right
oh yeah be careful i don't want him to
lose his food network show
you couldn't have don't say anything you
might regret but that's nice you're open
to letting her respond i'm pretty i'm
very open yeah yeah i think you just
sold your girlfriend to this couple
[Laughter]
it's on camera this human trafficking
interaction
she can consent
i mean maybe
gun to her head like the canadian was
afraid of
that's how we do it
no just kidding that's that's horrible i
shouldn't have said that
andrew uh what do you what do you think
about uh you know uh keys and
are you interested in uh
all this going on or a couple more
drinks yeah
i mean maybe so have you ever done it
with in a previous relationship i
haven't yeah never
okay
um
so you met your wife or your girlfriend
on hinge yeah
uh and
now your relationship is about to be a
little unhinged
uh
what uh what do you think you think uh
maybe you could go on the apps together
is that a possibility the apps together
the what it's an app so you can add
other couples or whatever
you look like you design apps how do you
not know what apps are
or appetizers on the food now
yeah we gotta do it in person like this
wait what's your job what's your job
i'm a business owner
like what kind of business
oh
man this is gonna be something really
liberal like a realistic sex doll
do you
do you make homemade vaccines for the
coronavirus
i own a fleet of trailers uh restroom
traders like upscale restroom trailers
porta potties
wait
do they go to coachella
not coachella compost
huh is it a compost burning man no
they're air-conditioned nice restroom
trailers like i've been in those like
but like where do you go like what kind
of place is burning man weddings
corporate events orgies yeah nothing
exciting
self-cleaning hopefully
wait are there bidets in them that's a
great idea i like i've been thinking
about that i want to do that i want to
play
for someone who likes his ass licked so
much yeah
and my friend is the engineer for tushy
so i'll hook you up all right yeah
see me after the show
white jewish man
are you jewish
uh blooded
like not religious secular is the word
you're looking for
[Music]
the blood thing was weird
i think that's the language hitler used
only the blooded jews
so uh does your is your what race is
your girlfriend
race she's caucasian
oh my god you guys don't give a [ __ ]
about anything do you
uh yeah she's a she's a boy
she's a gentile
uh what do you think if you took your uh
white girlfriend back to your jewish
parents would they be like i love her
yeah they love her they already met oh
yeah yeah is she pretty stingy as well
she saved napkins when you go to a
restaurant
wait is your mom like a jewish mom
like is she like overprotective and
stuff sort of i guess he said yes
i'm a little old to be like be protect
like yeah but jewish moms it never ends
until they die like that's just how they
are
so she's like that kind of did she make
you matzah ball soup
matzo ball soup
what'd she say
pop the tit out of your mouth okay i
thought you were telling me to pop my
tit out and i was so confused but that
makes sense yeah yeah i thought girls
like that i thought girls love that [ __ ]
you got a fat ass
no yeah i would have done it if you were
talking to me but like you weren't so
let's move on i need a transition so i
can verbally assault women
but
it doesn't count if you're trans i don't
think uh
andrew you look like ira glass uh you
ever listen to npr or did you just get
those glasses on a pledge
driver not a big npr fan
how did you get into restroom
trailers i was i'm i had a business
where i was uh renting trailers out to
truckers
and i was at a wedding and they had one
of these things i was like okay i just
i could do this you're like let's take a
bathroom on this really sell these
trailers do you ever put cameras in the
bathroom no no i'm not a creep not for
the creep just to see like who has
cocaine or something
like are your bathrooms clean enough for
people to do cocaine in them and feel
good about it yes i think so that should
be your marketing stance for sure i
could help you
keys what do you do i'm an executive
assistant
oh hell yeah yeah for who
um
i was working for a finance tech company
and well you can you can be an executive
assistant to any company there's always
ceos that don't know how to run their
company what separates an executive
assistant from an assistant
oh i think it's the level of who you
support in the company i thought you
were going to say the execution
but are you like in charge of a bunch of
other assistants no i'm just in charge
i'm not in charge of anyone i'm just
basically a strategic business partner
to
adults who run companies and don't know
how to organize their life so i'm like
the cliff notes for their job
well you don't look after kids
you got a three o'clock them to the
swingers clubs or is that super separate
that's you know what surprisingly it's
not super separate
it's it's successful take your boss to
an orgy day
no yeah that's actually really it so you
like people from work you've like talked
to them about the lifestyle and like
they or no you end up meeting them in
the lifestyle and you don't know and
you're like [ __ ] we work together do you
acknowledge it when you see each other
like you kind of know you're like hey
that's what's up okay is the pineapple
you're gliding by is the pineapple thing
true it's true and you know what we made
a mistake we thought a couple was
swinging because they had a pineapple on
their instagram we're like ah this
couple right here no they they were
no they weren't about tough times for
pineapple farming couples
what is the pineapple thing like
swingers use a pineapple as like a sign
of we are swingers to let other swingers
know upside down upside down pineapple
like they'll like put one on their front
porch sometimes or whatever you've seen
that or like in a grocery store they put
one upside down in their car i've seen
that no sometimes they do that to make
the juice more sweet
they want the juices
all right
you might confuse people to be swingers
just because of the symbol they're not
always swingers yeah you never know
they're just a little fruity or
something andrew's rethinking his
trailer bathroom logo right now
that's why there's so much white sauce
in the bathrooms
andrew are you intrigued by this
lifestyle well i'm intrigued by the pine
i thought
a pineapple made a guy's jizz taste
better yeah i mean a healthy diet makes
the guys use yes two birds one stone
[Laughter]
you signal and you do you eat a lot of
pineapple
wondering for myself
[Laughter]
is about to uh pineapple
you do
yeah i do don't i
enough not enough
she's like no he doesn't
[Laughter]
so what's the first thing that you would
do in uh in a threesome with your
girlfriend for the first time anything
that comes to mind
um
first thing i don't know after you sign
the nda
uh what would we do dim the lights and
just like
dim the lights
i might get a tan i don't know i don't
know you guys are both such attractive
people why would you do that in the dark
right that's i feel like you need to
practice some self-love
like take a bath
like look at yourself in the mirror yeah
see ya like you guys are both
very attractive people oh thank you you
need full lights on like apple store
lighting i feel like
go to molly for all your lighting needs
so
i want to like peer through the window
or something and have a good maybe take
molly
take care with you you can take some
molly
i'll help you find it
nice andrew
anything you want to say to seal the
deal with this foursome that's in the
works
um
let's get after it tonight a couple
drinks
a couple rounds
well you're gonna have to ask daddy so
that's not we'll talk later
he got that toilet money all the drinks
are on him
give it up for andrew and keys
[Applause]
future lovers
we got a whole
lgbtqia plus in here
keys oh that's her
she's already up here now we're entering
a fun part of the show
where we bring our cameraman slash
producer sam kuiper up on stage
and try to get him
a date
a beautiful beautiful date
ladies
this man is
five foot nine inches of pure alabama
steel he
hails from tuscaloosa
he's handy with a backhoe and
he's got hair gel for days
i feel like i'm being auctioned off
right now hans
uh any takers any takers please come
right on up the stairs we're just gonna
see if anyone please sir sit down
we're looking for a woman
i feel like he's trying to date me right
now why did he just move the table so
close
the lighting i'm just helping out the
sam doesn't believe in kovid he's not
that last guy on camera was sitting a
little too far to the left uh right he
was behind the pole so sorry dude
you missed your moment
he's on the clock right now a little
feedback dylan any of you indiana ladies
dallas
hey bring it bring indiana back up here
i was i lived in indiana for 10 years
where's bedford
i want the dallas woman to go
here we go dallas in the house
no snitch she's coming up here with an
attitude
she means business
she's not going to get bullied by this
elephant
i'm saying i'm nice to meet you yeah
ally and sam one minute starting now so
you're not a snitch no i'm not a stitch
what do you do
what do i what what do you do if you're
not snitching what are you i'm a
dietitian so i'm also in healthcare okay
so you tell people how to not get type 2
well
you can't just develop type 2 because of
your diet there's a lot of complications
with that so genetics okay
but i thought type 1 was genetics i'm
interested
oh yeah no no you're good um no so like
type 1 and type 2 have genetic
components so yeah
my friends are laughing because she's
talking about diabetes what is your like
uh what was the fun fact you learned
when you were in like
dietitian school or nutrition school
um
was there anything that surprised you
you were like
cocaine's good for you or
um
that vitamins are a scam
people like what like specific vitamins
are all
like if you don't have a certain
condition or you're
you know you eat three times a day you
really don't need vitamins
interesting okay
interesting so you're anti-vitamins
and time give it up for sam and ally
when you guys were talking about type
one type two i thought it was herpes
almost the entire time oh [ __ ] i don't
know about that there's a type two
herpes yeah you get it from eating
pineapple oh damn
[Laughter]
sorry buddy you got the wrong way so
gets it from gliding as though you said
[Laughter]
that's it so uh what do you think about
this southern boy do you think that uh
you know he can
wrestle a hog
he looks strong
like strong and
strong and tight
like my immune system or like my
physical strength physical strength i
don't know about your immune system yeah
yeah were you breastfed or now
i was formula fed his immune system is
probably not that good
were you a preemie
i'm offended uh
no i wasn't uh i don't know
if preemies like being called preemies
though so that actually might be the
biggest
to a dude though that i feel like that's
worse than calling a man short is asking
that took me that took me back i didn't
know what to say i've i've honestly
never
premie
he was like a preemie this guy
he had the same look on his face that uh
you did when someone
insulted you at an orgy
no yeah like if you ask a woman that
that's like he thinks i'm skinny but if
you ask
try this
new dieting trick have your babies two
months early oh yeah oh no they'll be 30
pounds of underweight for their whole
life man
[ __ ] my mom why'd you handle
[Laughter]
yeah carrying the baby carrying a girl
to term is like like bad parenting
oh yeah i agree oh yeah like i could
have been a skinny legend and
my mom was just like it'll come when it
comes
to undercook your babies yep yes uh
sally
or ali ali uh
looking at sam right now what would you
say he needs in his diet
no comment what do you mean
i'm not gonna i'm interested tell me
improve my life please for free i don't
know eat fruits and vegetables whole
grains legumes oh god that's like the i
didn't have to go i saw that laminated
paper i know a lot of people don't
people don't know that like the thousand
pound sisters don't know that but like i
feel like people know that
to eat fruits and vegetables i don't
know beans you'd be surprised a lot of
people don't eat i know i heard i heard
sorry to cut you off let tell me this is
true i got a question so i heard like
people say lettuce like iceberg lettuce
has no nutritional value but like they
say
that it does have good fiber
is that true it has nutritional value
all foods have nutritional value i mean
everything is calories right so even
still fuel
so the myth i get maybe you can
recommend him some vitamin d
give it up for sally and sam they fight
or ally and
sam they went on a date sam is now
uh a happy cameraman he's gonna get all
the angles right
uh because he we found him a date
finally he's been single for too long is
kind of getting sad actually he's kind
of a loser but so thank you sally or ali
for going on a date
yeah he
we're gonna send it back to his basement
now someone from this table needs to
[ __ ] the bandana boy
that's all i'm saying just someone
please yeah or he's going to join this
couple or he's going to shoot up a
school please do something
round rock high school he had no spirit
he has no ties to that school
but he has ties to us because he went on
a date on this show the first time he's
talked to a woman
since he killed that queen bee today
molly what'd you think about the dates
tonight um i thought they were
interesting some were freaky some were
kind of chill and virginy and
i it was a good mix of dates tonight
sometimes there's like
five people
yeah a lot of autism but tonight like
there were a lot of cool personalities a
lot of herpes i honestly vibed with all
of you and even though i was mean to the
canadian like i did like her
so yeah
canada in the house i would be friends
with almost all of you i won't say the
one that
i don't want my school shut up
give it up for molly vivint
you can check her out on instagram thank
you guys so much good night stay tuned
for the next show
[Music]
thanks for coming everybody but now we
gotta clear the show